this video is sponsored by audible
listen to a free audiobook and to
audible originals with a link in the
description Singapore is not known for
its subtlety from the minute you land
and see the world's tallest indoor
waterfall inside the airport you're
inundated with beautiful clean and green
architecture the site of extraordinary
lush buildings is so common that it
almost becomes boring all the rest
though pale in comparison to one what
the Eiffel Tower is to Paris or the
Opera House to Sydney
the Marina Bay Sands is to Singapore you
just can't visit without taking a photo
in this one small resort area is the
famous gardens by the bay flower dome
cloud forest outdoor event Piazza
Convention Centre theatre art and
science museum luxury mall - floating
crystal pavilions and finally three
tower 55 story hotel with the world's
highest pool on top altogether the
Marina Bay Sands Resort cost 5.5 billion
dollars making it the fifth most
expensive building in the world perhaps
the only subtle thing about it is oddly
enough also the reason it was built the
casino Singapore has long been a popular
destination for tourism beyond its use
of English far more than its closest
competitor Hong Kong it's also well
known for its beauty lack of crime and
cleanliness as an aviation hub with one
of the world's best airlines it's also
cheap and easy for Asian travelers to
get to from Bangkok a hundred and
sixteen US dollars round-trip on average
and two hours and 15 minutes
two hundred and nineteen dollars and
four hours and 44 minutes from Taipei
and $318 and eight hours a quick hop
relatively speaking from Sydney but back
in the early 2000s Singapore found
itself losing to its many regional
competitors it's a share of tourism in
the asia-pacific region shrunk from 30
point one percent in 1991 to just five
point eight percent by 2004 this was
attributed in part to its lack of
natural physical attractions a symptom
of its small size today Singapore has
only one of the 1121 total UNESCO World
Heritage Sites its botanical gardens and
at the time none neighboring Malaysia
meanwhile has for Vietnam eight and
Thailand five all three of which are
well-known inexpensive destinations to
stay competitive and revive its national
image the Singapore government surprised
everyone in 2004 when it floated the
radical idea of legalizing casinos for
decades after making them illegal
culturally casino gambling was
considered destructive and fundamentally
at odds with the country's very
conservative mentality and willingness
to ban or regulate just about anything
social and religious groups protested a
rare sight in authoritarian Singapore
and 30,000 people signed a petition in
opposition to see no bumper stickers
could be seen on cars and hundreds of
polls surveys and dialogues were held it
soon became known that the city states
then 4 million people were roughly
evenly divided on the issue and calls
were made for a referendum an indicator
of how passionate the public had become
then in April of 2005 just 13 months
later it was all over the government
announced it would allow the
construction of not one but two casino
resorts one in the centrally located
Marina Bay and the other on the southern
island of santosa
for comparison sydney debated the merits
of opening casinos for a full six years
but for the Singaporean government this
quick effective and sometimes
contradictory decision-making is
characteristic in 1987 for example its
Family Planning slogan was changed from
stop at to directly to have three or
more if you can afford it in any case
the government had made up its mind and
began soliciting work
for concepts from interested bidders
importantly the government invented the
now popular term integrated resort to
describe a single development with an
attached hotel Convention Center
entertainment theme parks luxury retail
shops fine dining and yes a casino this
was its billion-dollar hint to bidders
although they were interested at first
and foremost in developing one of
Singapore's first casinos they were to
be designed as iconic and symbolic
national landmarks of the nineteen
submitted proposals 14 were shortlisted
and four continued with formal bids
finally in May 2006 the Las Vegas Sands
corporation was selected for Marina Bay
thanks to its proven success in Nevada
and Macau also crucial was the architect
Israeli mo che softie who at age 27 had
designed Montreal's famous habitat 67
softies impressive proposal for a three
tower block design was cleverly modeled
after playing cards each of the three
towers would be composed of two
structures one flats and one curved ten
times more than the Leaning Tower of
Pisa this unique concept breaks
conventional rules of architecture and
that higher floors actually become
larger and larger until they reached the
hotel's three most expensive and
luxurious chairman Suites as if not
ambitious enough there was only a 27
month window for construction which
required a four-day cycle meaning an
entire floor would need to be completed
every four days to stay on track the
Singapore government argued that a hotel
this grand deserved an equally
impressive pool it was decided that a
three acre 340 meter long Park would be
built on top complete with jogging paths
for swimming pools an observation deck
promenade restaurants spa and 900
species of plants called the sky park it
resembled a ship sailing above Singapore
beautiful as it was the port presented
several significant challenges first how
to get it up ultimately the hole was
constructed on the ground in 14 sections
then lifted into place at a slow safe
speed of 46 feet per hour 16 hours to
lift each side
and all the way second as infinity pools
the water needed to flow evenly to
create the illusion of falling off the
top this despite the fact that the
380,000 gallon pools also laid on top of
350 five-story towers which would sink
over time as their foundation shifted
each at a different rate and all
susceptible to wind to protect against
this for joins were placed beneath each
pool capable of moving up to 500
millimetres to offset any changes
getting the pool from Indiana took more
than 30 cargo ships and the park alone
was itself a 150 million dollar project
when it's soft opened in 2010 the Marina
Bay Sands was neither the world's nor
Singapore's tallest building rather it
turns heads for somehow being somewhat
absurd fantastic and iconic all at the
same time it's one of those few
buildings which retains its beauty no
matter the angle vantage points or time
of day inside the hotel visitors are
greeted with a stunning hollow atrium
the pools create the sensation of
swimming on top of skyscrapers while the
other side of the sky Park offers a view
of the garden and endless flow of
container ships passing through the
strait the attached mall with its indoor
canal is somehow just as impressive
further south is Resorts World Sentosa
it features a more family-friendly
environment with an aquarium waterpark
Universal Studios Wax Museum hotel
complex and Singapore's other casino
although less architectural II
impressive Resorts World Sentosa is
remarkable for its sheer density of
attractions unsurprisingly both
locations have been hugely successful
the Marina Bay Sands has quickly become
the world's most profitable casino and
been a huge source of growth for the
Singapore economy as of 2018 the tiny
city-state receives more international
visitors than New York Dubai or Paris
and only fewer than Macau London Bangkok
and Hong Kong this was and is the best
case for legalizing casinos here or
anywhere proponents argue it's easy
money that there's
no faster way to create wealth out of
thin air amazingly Singapore's two
resorts contribute between 1.5 and 2% of
its entire GDP they create an estimated
20,000 jobs directly in the form of
dealers and specters hotel staff and
retainers cashiers slot attendants and
so on and an additional thirty to forty
thousand indirectly not only do they
attract more tourists but also
higher-quality business travellers and
VIPs on the other hand some are
skeptical of the economic benefits
suggesting increased tax revenue is
offset by increased expenditures in the
form of enforcement infrastructure and
not to be forgotten the social costs of
casinos while the majority of
Singaporeans admit to gambling
themselves in some form most also
believe casinos are unique in the way
they encourage addiction their interiors
are designed with the express intent of
keeping players inside as long as
possible which for a small minority
leads to pathological behavior this tiny
group of people then disproportionately
cost their communities in the form of
lost productivity bankruptcy crime
welfare and of course the suffering of
their families casinos unlike races or
cruises are available 24/7 it's said
that a casino within 10 miles of a
person's home leads to a 90% increase in
the odds of that person becoming a
pathological gambler one 2005 study also
estimated such a person costs themselves
in their community nineteen thousand
seven hundred and eleven dollars on
average a year casinos also target
specific culturally Volleyball groups
for instance by adhering closely to Fung
Shui principles to play on superstition
still others accept a combination of
these arguments they argue that players
will travel to wherever gambling is
available the only question is whether
to capture their spending locally in the
US for example states are more likely to
legalize casinos when their neighbors do
first in Singapore gamblers have always
had easy access in Malaysia and
and on cruises this was one of the
primary rationales for Singapore's
decision back in 2005 why not benefit
from what's already going to happen but
although it would do the unthinkable and
open the door to casinos it would do so
in a uniquely Singaporean way while
every other gambling hub in the world
flaunts its casinos for all they're
worth Singapore has been very careful to
balance profit with the attendant social
costs arguably at great expense from the
very beginning the National Development
Commission stipulated the casino could
not occupy more than 3 to 5 percent of
the total resort space the original plan
for strong Venetian theme and monorail
connecting the casino to the ferry
terminal were later replaced at the
insistence of the government with the
sky park and pool the resort is also the
company's only property where the
location proceeds The Sands brand in its
name a subtle reflection of the
project's focus the original architect
an expert and casino design was later
replaced with softy who is instead known
for impressive and unique architecture
the two gaps between the building's
three towers grant a view of the sea
beyond it it complements rather than
intrudes on the skyline in contrast to
most casinos in practice this means the
Marina Bay Sands is neither as tacky as
Vegas or shady as Macau it's an
immediate iconic symbol of Singapore you
might spend hours shopping eating
swimming even stay at the hotel but
aside from the occasional sign you may
not even notice the existence of the
casino where the company makes roughly
seventy percent of its profit for its
part the government has also taken
tangible steps to reduce problematic
behavior family members can request
their loved ones be barred from gambling
those under 21 are forbidden from
entering casinos and ATMs are not
available inside the gambling areas most
significantly Singapore residents are
required to pay an entry fee of a
hundred and fifty dollars or three
thousand per year to access each resort
neither of which are allowed to refund
or reimburse that fee today 10 years
after their Grand Openings most people
would say Singh
or has succeeded its reaped the economic
benefits while at the same time managing
the effects still in hiding its casinos
it runs the risk of also hiding their
damage their casualties their hardships
by taxing dubious behavior Singapore not
only deters its and profits from it but
also risks economically depending on it
after Singapore is sanitized making
itself clean green and its vices unseen
it's easy to forget what's lost if
casinos economics and the economics of
casinos interest you you're going to
love my upcoming 30-minute documentary
about a very related topic I've been
saying this for a while but this time I
promise it's written recorded and coming
quite soon in the meantime you should
listen to the also related story of how
two mathematicians apply their genius to
the game of blackjack and then use their
knowledge to win on Wall Street this
story called fortunes formula has just
about everything that interests me
economics business finance and a
fascinating narrative and you can listen
to it along with thousands of other
audiobooks with audiblelistener oh my
self you can listen to them in the
shower on the way to work or school or
while playing video games you can
download them for offline with their
free mobile apps and membership gives
you access to any one audiobook a month
plus two audible originals go to my link
in the description audible.com slash
poly matter that's a you DIBL EECOM
slash pol y ma TT er or txt pol Y m8 ete
r2 500 - 500 for 30 day free trial
things to audible for sponsoring this
video and to you for watching
you